no we don't play that we don't play that
oh now that that's a great hit right
[Applause]
there
hi my name is brandon copeland outside
linebacker for the new york jets
and today i'm gonna be reacting to some
hard hits
some of my favorite football movies are
friday night lights
love friday night lights it just reminds
you of like you said what you played for
why you started playing
obviously everyone loves remember the
titans it's denzel
come on now that's the easy one
everybody remembers the the songs in the
movie
and the different hardships the team had
to go through but you know that's
obviously a classic so
you always love that the hardest hit
i've ever given i caught this
quarterback
scrambling he talked big trash big trash
talker
he was scrambling he didn't see me
catch up to him from the side and i laid
homie out
literally laid him out his coach
actually was complaining at halftime in
the media
interview so that's how hard i hit homie
that was my biggest hit but i'm really
excited to see these hits so
i probably need to take some notes boom
all right so we got the longest yard
here oh yes the big dude
[Music]
oh he sent him on a bounty he broke in
my nose dude
the comms don't seem to have an answer
for dunham who's averaging close to 12
yards a carry this half
that's a good hit that's a clothesline
that's that's
i think i made him himself
yeah now that that that's a good hit i
don't see anything wrong with that that
was beautiful
formed clothesline got low kept his pads
low
kept his head up you can't you can't
beat that any sending them out on the
stretcher
that's a good good hit i'm gonna give
him a thumbs up on that one okay
we got water boy stop making fun of me
oh now that's textbook now that's a
textbook tackle me
personally i like the clothesline from
longest yard a little bit better but
that right there that is going to turn
some coach's eyes you might see him
playing on sundays if he's tackling like
that that was good
i'm not going to give it a hardest hit i
think it's a form tackle i like it
though
i'm gonna give it a thumbs down i'm
gonna be a hard
judge on this one yeah let's go let's
see what we got next this is the blind
side here
big mock come
at a certain point you just got to fall
bro
that's some pride fall quick give up
see we had to fight
[Applause]
i guess you have to that's not a hit
that's textbook blocking he had his
hands inside
all that type of stuff then threw him
out the club he told the dude we don't
allow timberland boots
in the club i told you one time before
get out of here kid and he took him and
threw him over the fence through him
about the club that i got to give you a
thumbs up on that one
i like more disrespectful stuff so the
clothesline and throwing people out the
club i guess i'm
disrespectful next one gridiron again
classic this is dwayne johnson damn 88.
i remember this
[Music]
rival gang members playing it out on the
line for each other that's football
now that's a good hit they laid his
whole body out there on the line they
rival
gangs but on the football field all of
us come together
textbook block right there textbook hit
he didn't only just fall he rolled it's
a big dust pile right there his whole
jersey dusty
that's a thumbs up right there i i want
to play with that guy
put it like that next one the
replacement
classic movie right there
[Applause]
oh danny bateman
sorry i just love the conversation
that's a that's a good hit i think i'm a
little biased the quarterback hits
i'mma grade this one down a little bit
too just because
we're not allowed to do half of this
stuff anymore like even the way that the
guy fell on top of
falco right there i would get fined for
that maybe i'm a little jealous
and i'm gonna go ahead and admit that to
you but i'm gonna give it a thumbs down
because i can't do it pick my shirt
next one yeah i'm a hater say what you
want to say about me
express syracuse upstate new york
[Music]
jupiter
hell oh hell see
now that was a good hit well that was a
late hit that's some dirty
right there that's some dirty right
there and with the racial
overtones is i know it's supposed to say
undertones but it's overtones
i'mma say thumbs down that's th that's
disgusting and degrading you know what
that's a good hit though
but that's disgusting and degrading man
man next one that's crazy rudy
is it crazy i've never seen rudy
no i'm not the oh oh
i see i was gonna hate on this one oh
[Music]
now that that was a good hit you know
i'ma just give it a good hit though i'm
not gonna give it a great
great hit as a linebacker my coach would
be very happy
seeing that type of read and reaction
right there but i'm not gonna give it a
great hit
i'm gonna give him a thumbs down cause
i'm the judge
it's my show i'll say it again remember
the titans
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
oh see
the racial overtones again
that was a good hit i ain't gonna lie to
you that was a good hit
like i said i don't like it but he
played between the whistles now
so i got it it was a clean hit and when
he got up he talking all that extra
stuff
i don't have to like it but i gotta give
my man a thumbs up that's a good hit
that's a great hit i'll give you that
these
all of this y'all got me hyped out of
all the movies i'm still going
longest yard football isn't about
textbook and things don't always work
out perfectly
this man just literally put out his arm
and clothesline the hell out of home
i gotta give it them two thumbs up
longest shot
[Music]
you